Nihat damia is a political campaigner
through and through from sunup to
sundown he can be found working the
streets of Istanbul Scott eco district
he's drumming up support for the
pro-kurdish HDP but voters who don't
cross his path are unlikely to learn
much about the party's program many
Turkish media outlets don't report on
them we don't get any airtime on Turkish
TV we're practically invisible
there are broadcasters and newspapers
that have reported on us but they've
been shut down they want to make it
difficult for us we're not gonna give up
according to the watchdog reporters
without borders more than 80% of Turkish
media are owned by companies close to
president add one that is particularly
evident during election campaigning for
example in the last two weeks of May
turkeys public broadcaster trt spent
more than 68 hours reporting on Outlands
campaign opposition leader mora min Jay
and his CHP were given only six hours of
airtime Marillac Sheena's 'party
featured for just 13 minutes the HDP
candidates a lot in Dima Tosh has never
been shown on air the pro-kurdish HDP in
particular faces many difficulties
president Iran has effectively declared
the party an enemy of the state he
accuses it of spreading terrorist
propaganda and having ties to the
militant PKK group because of this the
HTTP presidential candidate salat
indomita runs his campaign from jail he
has been in custody for more than
one-and-a-half years a presidential
candidate standing from inside prison
that's a first for Turkey the EU and
international observers have sharply
criticized the government's handling of
damia tache but that doesn't help him
much his election campaigning has so far
been limited to social media recently on
Twitter he asked Turkey's largest news
broadcasters why they have never
reported
his campaign but he didn't get an answer
in a written interview with DW he said
there's no justification why in these
critical times the media are opting to
see no evil hear no evil and speak no
evil and why they're serving the
interests of the government for Nihad
damia the HDP campaigner in istanbul
such obstacles are just part of everyday
life but despite the challenges he
continues he says the harder life
becomes for his people the harder he
will work for change